hello welcome to science sangha i'm
Sadashiva pi today we have a dr. Alison
mater II associate professor University
of California San Diego's School of
Medicine Department of Pediatrics and
the cellular and molecular medicine is
with us dr. moti has won several
distinctions that I was to his credit
and I'm going to mention only a few of
them here in 2009 he won National Center
of leadership in academic medicine UCSD
in 2009 again he won NH the directors
new Innovation Award in 2000 morale
foundation Young Investigator award in
2010 he was 100 most influential people
in Brazil in 2000 cell stigma Buster
from National Alliance and mental
illness award so I can go on and I will
mention couple of them at the end in
2016 he one faculty innovator award from
UCSD and this year already has won a
leadership in research award of
excellence by pence Hospital in addition
he is in the review board of several
publication occasions and he has won
several so for grants and all so welcome
dr. Allison the science hang out all
right thank you very much thank you for
the invitation and thank you for
organizing besom the more we spread
about the science the better of you okay
thank thank you very much yeah let's get
going let's talk about can you please
tell me about yourself a little bit
about your background education etc yeah
so I'm actually originally from Brazil I
got my pigeon ethics in 2001 and in
Brazil we don't have like a very strong
neuroscience community I always wanted
to get involved with neuroscience so I
felt that I was
after the PGD was the time to go abroad
in and explore a little bit as a postdoc
so that's when huh
Rusty's gauge lab at the Salk Institute
work with nearest task neurogenesis and
he was a postdoc there for several years
we have very nice publications were very
productive time for me that that was in
2000 end of 2008 2009 I became a system
professor here at UC San Diego and
established my own lab in in the lab we
are mostly focused on neurological
disorders try to model using human stem
cells I was a very fortunate because
during the whole doc period I was able
to learn how to grow human in growing
stem cells and when I started my lab
that was when the whole IPS revolution
induced pluripotent stem cells
revolution from Shinya Yamanaka appear
in the literature so I was able to jump
in into the technology and was among
probably the first users of the IPS
reprogramming technology to model
neurological disorders so since then my
lab has been focusing on comparing
disease models with controls and try to
understand not only what happens when
you have a specific genetic alteration
what happens to your brain cells to your
neurons your astrocytes
but also use that to screen potential
drugs that may be able to ameliorate or
even revert the neurological disorder
that that we are studying so I feel that
this is a very exciting model because
it's not a static model and let me put
this way I mean there are different
models and models are simplify
representations of the reality take
animal model you can mimic a human
disease in the animal model but that's
it that's how far the model will go I
mean it's an animal
I feel that we do the stem cells we are
still learning how to create better
models so in the beginning we are used
to do lots of neurons in in model layers
now we can grow them with some
organization in organoids so all of that
is this - evolving so we can also create
organoids they're a little bit bigger
because they have something that seems
like a pascal organization system so it
can improve upon the tools that we have
so we are always getting closer and
closer to the reality which is the human
brain so I feel that this is a promising
model new and exciting so my lab has
about 17 people now a dogs some grad
students master students volunteers and
the grads and technicians but I feel
that it is very lively atmosphere
everybody is very supportive to each
other when good things that we all share
the same tools we're always using the
same methodology but asking different
questions so instead of a competitive
environment that you may find like in
other medium-sized big labs I feel that
I was able to create something that was
very collaborative because people can
view the pond each other and everybody
grows together this is the kind of
environment that we try to keep going
here and UC San Diego I'm also part of
the Sanford Consortium for regenerative
medicine this is a new initiative from
the SERM SRM which is the stem cell
California institution and together with
a philanthropic donation from many same
fort we were able to create this consort
and putting together lots of labs like
like like mine that are using stem cells
to learn about human diseases from the
basic fundamental aspects to a more
translational Pro
so it's all in one we are combined we
are constantly discussing how to take
what we learn from the bench to the
bedside how to translate everything that
we learn as fast as possible to the
patient so in a nutshell this is a an
introduction to my lab ok
yeah ok can you talk about your mentors
role models in your career I think I
have like really good mentors my first
PhD advisor dr. Kawas manky in Brazil he
was a very scientific rigorous guy
always wanted us to to do the
experiments that was was perfect not
afraid of repetition many times to
convince ourselves that the data was was
was really good and once you have good
data you can build upon so I think he
was the first one to point to me that
rather than rushing and have something
just weaken Authority but do something
that is for sure so you spend your time
but at the end you gain quality so that
was the first one and they all say that
my postdoc advisor rusty gauged an
amazing guy full of energy very creative
looked forward and and I was able to
also get inspired by him in in he in
u.s. he was very helpful to to point me
to the right directions or or to discuss
alternatives coming from south of
America the u.s. system of doing science
is very different when I started my
postdoc I barely speak English always
with lots of lots lots to learn and he
was a patient of and kind enough to
guide to point into a device so those
two were really my major role models in
science and in addition I know you are a
busy person with all the different
projects going on writing client send
all those things
so what are
hobbies do you have other than science
no here in San Diego I mean I learned
how to sorry I there he is a good part
of that in in in in the outdoors right
really enjoying the outdoors we have a
son he's 10 years old and we like to
take him out camping and explore hiking
just being touch with nature I think
that this is this is good for for my
brain with so much into science and
sometimes I mean doing something
different
it helps you to to think more clearly to
to give a break to your to your brain so
these are the major activities that that
we do when I'm not in the lab that's
what we're gonna find me okay and coming
to the research like what are the
different projects what are the
different diseases you are looking at
currently in the lab so the lab I would
say there are three major lines of
research they all converge into trying
to understand the same thing which is
the big picture is the social the human
social brain what is so unique about the
social brain and why I mean seeing the
social brain is because is one of the
characteristics that distinguish us from
other primates so the human brain really
evolved to become a social entity so
from the beginning from the day we are
born we are seeking social interactions
so for some reason evolution thought
that we are collaborative animals and we
evolved to that and probably that's why
we are here we can create arts we can
create signs and other animals cannot do
that I think this is part because our
social brain the power of our social
brain so I try to understand that in one
way to understand something is to look
for when something goes wrong or the so
called mutants in nature and and
for the social brain would be someone
with autism for example that does not
have that social drive it is afraid or
sometimes do not know how to take
advantage of the human social brain so
autism is a big part of my lab we focus
on different genes that can lead to
autism and and on the other end of the
spectrum we have other types of mutants
genetic alterations that can make makes
you hyper social so this is for example
what we see in women syndrome before
affected with wheelin syndrome and I
actually become attracted to strangers
they like the new faces there's so much
more social than than the normal so
that's a striking phenotype and again
it's just like a mutation a deletion in
chromosome 7 that makes you hyper social
so why is that how those genes can
actually change your behavior so looking
from a disease perspective this is the
portfolio of diseases that that we
choose to work on namely mirror genetic
disorders that will affect your social
brain then there is the other part of
the lab that looks into that question
from a more evolutionary perspective so
we try to understand how the human brain
evolved to become a social brain and
this is a we do that by comparing the
cells or the early stages of neuro
development from humans compared to
other non-human primates for example the
chimpanzee so we have cellar models for
those tree species and we we compare we
use each other to contrast and see what
are the differences and the differences
might appear at the genetic level I
appear at the molecular level at the
cellar level in at the network level so
we have different layers of complexity
in we just try to understand what's
unique really unique about
the human brain and finally I have
another line a third line of research
and this is a follow-up from my
postdoctoral work where we figure out
that there are regions discrete regions
in the genome called retro element or
Retta transposons so these are quite
ancient DNA regions repetitive regions
that are spread up to the chromosomes
that have this remarkable ability to
make copies of themselves and to insert
back into the genome so when they do
that we call them the jumping genes when
they do that they expand the genome and
by expanding the genome they provide a
fertile soil for evolution to act or
even at the somatic level for some
alterations in transcription in splicing
sites so whenever there is a movement
from one of those jumping genes the
cells become distinct it is distinct at
the genetic level because it now has a
new de novo genetic scar into the genome
and it's different from the neighborhood
cell so it creates what we call genetic
mosaicism
and those insertions may actually affect
how the cells behave and we have some
examples of that single insertion can
make a cell for more synapses compared
to to another insertion so we don't know
yet if this is an important phenomenon
by law biology might be that it happens
in the brain because neurons are post
mitotic cells they just don't care they
will not define so they are somehow
protected but it might be the other way
may be that this is a very conserved
mechanism to generate genetic diversity
in your brain and this diversity might
actually be important on on on on on how
you think about everything so it might
be the detector that make us
individually unique so we we work with
those two hypotheses or three let's put
this way one is a positive hypothesis so
those things are improving the fitness
of the individual or the species there
is a neutral hypothesis they're just
there we don't care or or the tomato
hypothesis whenever it happens is
actually bad for you and on support of
these third hypothesis we have been
[Music]
having some correlational studies
between mental disorders autism and
schizophrenia mainly with a high level
of Retta transposition so it seems like
we have too much it's probably bad for
you but again I mean this is early
stages of a very unexplored field and we
don't know where it's gonna take her so
it's I would say this is a more
exploratory side of the lab okay and
what are you going to present today I'm
gonna talk like an overview of different
projects in the lab using IPS we've
we've mutations in some genes that cause
that effect is the social brain mainly
autism can you please go ahead and do
the presentation thank you
all right so I believe you were seeing
of course this light now yeah yeah all
right okay okay so as a nation a major
focus in my lab is to explore autism and
autism is not only interesting from the
aspect of the human social brain but it
is also a condition that affects many
people actually one in 54 boys will be
born with autism so that's a quite high
number and those numbers have been
changing lately we mainly have data from
us and in England but it seems like
quite conserved across the world
and we think that the increase numbers
are probably or in frequency are
probably due to a better diagnostic
people know more about autism doctors
are more familiar we are talking more
about the condition than we did in the
past years we don't know much about
autism but we know that in some cases
that is a strong genetic component and
in other cases it seems like is more
driven or or caused by environmental
causes and we don't fully understand how
those two interact I mean we know that
probably they do interact each other but
isn't clear yet how this happens and
because we have so many people with
autism this is quite a burden for the
system so economically it's quite heavy
on the state on the government but also
for the families this is too much so
this is what we expect as a cost during
the lifetime of someone with autism 3.2
Millions
and these will go into special school
special education stare apiece in all
the service that they need you have one
has to remember that people with autism
experience the world in a different way
so even simple tasks as going to the
dentist is not
easy for people with autism so they may
require a special dentist that knows how
to deal with the condition that has a
special settings to treat people with
autism so these all increase the cost of
living with someone with autism more
importantly towards the fact that there
is no cure there is no such a magic pill
that one can take and revert autism so
this is quite frustrating
most of the medicines that we have out
there these are for to treat the
symptoms of autism and one example is
the fact that 20-30 percent of people
with autism might develop seizures at
one point in life and so we can take
drugs to control the seizures same thing
is for GI irritations and you might take
like some drugs to control that but
really for the core of autism there is
no drug that would make you more social
for example or we speed up your Lenny
learning ability or improve your
language so these are core deficits of
autism that we have no medications no
cure and as I mentioned in the past the
model that we use is induced pluripotent
stem cells so it can reprogram a somatic
cells from individuals with with the
condition push them back to these early
embryonic stages or IPs seized and from
the IPS series we can make brain cells
and then we compared these brain cells
derived from autistic individuals to a
group of controls no affected
individuals and we look for differences
and you those differences might be at
the molecular level might be at the cell
level this Sylvie 3 level but
nonetheless if you find one of those
differences you might use that as a
readout in a drug screening platform for
example that will help you to speed up
drugs Coburg process so we're very
interesting on this translation of
aspects so when I started my lab I
didn't know exactly how to start but I
thought that was important to start with
we're genetically defined conditions
under the umbrella of autism in red
syndrome is one of them the clinical
phenotypes are more homogeneous it's two
variable but way more homogeneous than
overall autism and we know it's caused
by mutations in a gene called mecp2 so
we recruit individuals carrying
different mecp2 mutations both boys and
girls and in and we use skin cells of
fibroblasts as a source to reprogram the
cells and we start making neurons from
rats Engram regions and the interesting
part was in the beginning it wasn't
clear what to look for nobody has done
that before so I have to take you back
to like 2008 2009 and there was one
clear one paper describing morphometric
alterations done by Golgi staining in a
brain of a boy with red syndrome so you
can clearly see in the bottom here you
have different cortical layers staining
by by Gogi from a control case and on
top from the mecp2 knockout or mutant
ninja video and it's pretty clear that
those needles are leather bar eyes they
are smaller so they usually they look
like immature compared to controls so we
thought that morphology might be a best
way to do it so this is the protocol
that we have we keep improving the
protocol but we start with a
well-defined condition media and then we
grow the IPS seized from the IPS we make
in brig bodies and from the angry bodies
we make mirror rosettes and if you
dissociate this neural rosette they will
become neural progenitor cells and on
the bottom there are different
markers that will tell you that the
steps that you have are the right ones
and you can be confident that if you
just withdraw the growth factors from
the population of little progenitor
cells they will spontaneously
differentiate in what we call a mix the
narrow culture or a heterogeneous
culture because we have both excitatory
neurons inhibitory neurons in several
astrocytes in there depending on the
assay you can use facts or max magnetic
self sorting to isolate specific subtype
of neurons or specific subtypes of glial
cells and this is how the cells look
like if you played the neural progenitor
cells in the absence of growth factors
on the top you have a cluster of cells
and they would migrate out they will
follow the process of other cells that
have previously migrated and as they
approach the border these cells we stop
differentiate and start making
connections with the neighboring cells
and we characterize these cells using
different markers different technologies
more recently we have been focusing on
single-cell analysis because we want to
know what kind of neurons we have in our
dishes so this is a one example of a
free time machine where we can capture
single cells using these freedom wata
form and in each cell we can analyze the
expression of different genes and from
this data you can explore if the control
group are similar to the rat group so in
the bar graphics here what we have is
the controls in blue in the red syndrome
in red and just from the beginning you
can tell that layer 5 and 6 from red
syndrome are not as well represented as
we see in controls and already see that
the number of glutamatergic neurons or
cholinergic neurons in the retina
population is also not as represented as
the controls so the differentiation is
not identical between these groups there
are differences in the type of neurons
that we have on the other panel here we
just have a moody staining with
different cortical layer markers so it
can be confident that those neurons are
indeed glutamatergic glutamatergic
pyramidal cortical neurons so these are
80% of the neurons are this type of
neurons that we can get from the IPS C's
in this Nexus like this is there's just
a different analysis where we can use
the 10x it's a more powerful technology
so usually you can do RNA seek in single
cells and you have those maps that
display all the populations that we have
and similar to the fluid I machine we
can see it at the population of
glutamatergic neurons here in blue takes
a large fraction of the population we do
have a small population of GABAergic
neurons there is also some progenitor
cells going on and in red you can start
system via cells most of it are
astrocytes and in this is line we have
the first phenotypic data from rat
syndrome just showing that if you
measure the soma of these cells they are
not as big as the control so the soma
size is a slightly smaller compared to
the controls another dramatic phenotype
we see in those needles is the absence
of neuronal spines in the images here
you can see that the white type at the
control neurons they show lots of spines
in the rats Engram derived neurons we
don't see it all these phenotypes you
can validate using shrnas against mecp2
in the control or the Y type neurons to
mimic the phenotypes so we are confident
that this is caused by the mutations in
the mCP to gene but the most dramatic
phenotype
is the number of synapses that that we
see in those neurons and I just play a
video here of panoramic perspective of
the the synaptogenesis that we see in
these cultures in the left you have your
control cells in the right your retching
drop drive neurons and it's pretty clear
that although the number of neurons are
similar in red the number of synaptic
Punta in red here are reduced in rats
Ingram compared to controls and it is a
pretty dramatic reduction so they don't
make as many synapses as we see in
controls and this is the quantification
so it's a little bit lower than 50% but
the good part is that this is not
something permanent or fixed if you
expose these red Syndrome neurons to a
specific drugs such as igf-1
insulin-like that one you can actually
revert that so the red single neurons
would behave similar as the control
group so it points is suggest to us that
these conditions can be reverted
eventually if we know how to do it if we
have drugs that can actually penetrate
into the brain and use the activity of
those synapses so everything that we did
with bouddhiste knees can be
recalculated using electrophysiology
here is our collaborator a gold chain
who did that in a blind fashion so you
can patch Club control cells or rats in
themselves and visually after doing lots
of recordings you realize that the rats
Engram cells have a decreased frequency
of spontaneous postsynaptic currents
similar to what when we predict with a
lower number of excitatory synapses so
it's always nice when you have different
complementary technologies that points
you in the same direction so this is
possible with neurons in 2d cultures
Verizon nation we can use these
technology to grow cells in three
dimension and this is what we call
cerebral organoids where we have some
kind of organization there are a
ventricular zones that my keep stem
cells or present ourselves and those
house who migrated out inform the
cortical plate once they reach the
cortical plate they can also migrate
both radio and NJ so in a tangential
pattern and we start to see some kind of
organization so the cells more organized
as these organoids mature you can see a
better definition between the cortical
layers and in the electrical activity as
well we use several markers again
similar to what we did in 2d to
visualize these different cortical
layers and at the functional level we
did several experiments this is just a
video of a voltage-gated dye so you can
see that on neurons are pre active so
they are spontaneously firing inside
this organoids so this is was done with
a confocal microscopy to two-photon
microscopy we can do the same thing with
calcium dye and again I mean you can see
calcium transients in coming from from
these needles and you can trace them and
you can basically confirm that they are
active but to me the really cool
function of analysis is when you plate
this cerebral organoids
in a multi electrode dish and this is
something that was developed by a former
postdoc in the lab Cassiano and so he
basically placed some of those mini
brains on these multi electrode wells in
this case we have a 8x8 or 64 electrodes
and these electrodes will capture the
electrical activity and will generate an
activity map similar to this one that
I'm playing here so the more the rare
the higher the frequency and the
intensity of the board's so the machine
will actually speak what we call a
raster plot your on top we have examples
of a raster plot each channel is one
line and each trace is a spike event or
a neuron that's firing and if you have
too much of those spike events in a very
short of time we call that a burst and
if you have bursts that aligns in
several channels we call that a
synchrony even and over time we see that
these cells tend to reach or more
synchronized even so this is just over
time what happens at eight weeks we
start system activity 10 weeks the level
of activity becomes more frequent and at
12 weeks not only the activity is
increase you have way more activity but
the number of synchronization events
start to appear start to become clear so
this is what happens in a normal
situation now if you compare that with
Rett syndrome organoid we don't see as
many synchronized events as we see with
the control group so this is again
another indication that Rett syndrome
neurons will not develop as the controls
and will not reach out this level of
maturation an interesting approach that
we also use is to take advantage of
crispers or genome editing enzymes to
create mutations or in this case to
rescue the mecp2 mutation and by doing
that we were able to fully recover the
electrical activity those neurons can
now mature similar to controls this is
what the bar graph here suggests if you
see these a small art follow the RTT in
the gray bar this is our genome edit
rescue cell line so no longer carried
the mutation and the
of synchronicity increased to the
control level this is pretty cool
so we are using these kind of readouts
in a drug screening platform for example
we team up with the in cats at NIH where
they have these robot arms that will do
the screening of thousands and thousands
of drugs for us you know the bar graphs
here I have just some examples of drugs
that may actually increase the number of
synaptogenesis the last bar is igf-1 so
you can see that there are drugs that
are as good as if not better than izf
one so again I'm very optimistic about
this possibility of finding new drugs
and applied them to to the patient and
so some of the drugs can actually rescue
the networks so this is using the mucho
lack of the Rae so but another thing
that we can do if those cells is to
dissect the contribution of individual
cell lines and you have for example give
yourselves
I mentioned that we can make astrocytes
from these neural progenitor cells we
use a protocol that virtually gives you
a very homogeneous or even pure
population of Nia cells after sorting
and it's a quite fast protocol was
developed again by Cassie and together
with br-2 postdocs in the lab the
protocol is quite simple instead of
creating neurospheres you change the
medium to a medium that favors the
appearance of astrocytes and they would
migrate out from disasters as Astro
spheres in adding you have this
population of nice astrocytes so we use
now other sites to compare gene
expression between controls and rats and
we see different things
one example is genes that are highly
expressed in astrocytes such as JP
aquaporin and Hunter beta or by maintain
those genes are always
upregulated in rats Ingram compared to
controls an indication that the rat
syndrome astrocytes are kind of more
reactive compared to controls again we
don't fully understand how this happens
other phenotypes that we could see is
for example on the distribution of
calcium waves after an injury the red
circle here suggests that it points to
the cell line that we touch it with a
pipette and then you can follow the
calcium wave spreading out in the normal
situation in rats Engram astrocytes they
are unable to spread the calcium after
the injury so again there is something
wrong with those astrocytes that we
don't fully understand but those are
phenotypes that guide us to do a more
careful analysis such as a culture
experiments where we're gonna play
neurons on top of a mono layer of
astrocytes and see how the other sites
can instruct the neurons to behavior or
to differentiate anything these next
slide here I have an example of what
these astrocytes can do if you just mix
different genotypes for example white
type astrocytes white type neurons the
neurons develop quite well I'm just
showing here the neurons in green if you
plate the same control neurons but now
in a bed of Rett syndrome derived
astrocytes they fail to try they have
this bipolar looking not many
arborizations going on the same is true
if you have red syndrome euros and red
syndrome astrocytes
nothing really happens they again very
mature but to me the most dramatic data
is when we plate those red syndrome
neurons remember they carry the genetic
alteration and you place them in a bed
of normal astrocytes you fully rescue
the morphology they now look way better
the
indistinguishable compared to controls
we can actually quantify how this
different parameters number of being
rides neuronal length segments and even
number of synapses and they do look like
normal neurons so again it's a it's a
mutant Europe but in the right
environment will behave like a normal
neuron so this is very encouraging for
us and we have been looking for what
would be the toxic factor I apologize
for that the toxic factor coming from
the astrocytes again we use gene
expression to learn that red syndrome
astrocytes a Mis regulated signature of
cytokines and among the most ugly
regulated cytokines we have ir6 so the
the bar graphics here points to a high
level of i/o 6 in red single mutants or
in red syndrome artificially generated
knockout so by removing any CP 2 from
the cell you increase the levels of i/o
6 this is something that we also seeing
in impulse more than brain tissues as
well so I of 6 is a pro-inflammatory
signature so we thought that what
happens if you just expose normal
neurons to the same levels of io6 that
red senior astrocytes can generate and
the true is that I r6 at these very high
levels is very detrimental and this is
just one example of morphology we see
decreasing the total neuronal length the
number of synapses is decreased as well
in the overall spikes coming from the
multilateral array it's also decreased
in the presence of IR 6 so I all 6 seems
like one of these key molecules a
cytokine that may actually contribute to
Rett syndrome so we are further
exploring ways of taking advantage of
that information and use for example ir6
block
or neutralized antibodies to see if we
can ameliorate or improve the condition
of red syndrome patients how I also
mentioned that we are not only studying
red syndrome
again we start with Rett syndrome
because it was a easy entry to the
question to the biology because of the
wild define genetic alteration but we
have been collecting cells from no
distich kids for the past ten years and
we do that using social media we create
the tooth fairy kid collection where we
connect with the families using Facebook
for example and we send a kid with
instructions for the families to send
out their new tooth to the lab and from
this new tool we are able to isolate the
dental pulp cells and create IPS ease
from these materials so there is no need
for the families to come to the lab for
a skin biopsy for example so that
removes lots of stress from the families
to come to the lab and by having a large
collection of these cells we can now
model different types of autism in one
condition that we have been looking are
the ones with macro sets microcephalic
brains so there is a population of
autistic kids who have big brains the
volume of their brains are bigger
compared to controls compared to the
normal curve and it's only a fraction of
them but it's a large fraction it's
about 20% of them have these big brains
and if you just do a correlation between
the number of ki-67 cells these are
proliferative neural progenitor cells
there's a nice correlation with brain
volume so the autistic derived neural
progenitor cells they actually
proliferate faster or more compared to
controls and that might explain why they
have these
enlarged brains
and these in large brains one would
expect them to form more synapses but we
see the opposite you see that more
neurons does not necessarily mean more
synapses they actually have lower level
of excitatory synapses and this is
reflected on the overall network
formation so the number of spikes and
this synchronization is way reduced
income in autism compared to controls so
the the bar graph here is on the right
you can see just by the scale that is so
much different so basically these
autistic derived networks they don't
make lots of connections and we have
been testing IGF similar to what we did
with Ratzinger in India patek autism and
what we get is something quite
interesting it is not all the cells
responded in the same way so what we
have in those graphics here it is the
number of spikes or the electrical
activity from the motor lack of the rate
in non-treated this is the the black
curve or treated with igf-1 and the day
of treatment is indicated here by this
line here so all of those are autistic
derived networks and you can see that
the top ones for example after adding I
just went to the culture the number of
spikes go up they responded really well
really fast why Jeff one in the bottom
ones you have like three networks that
do not respond as well to igf-1 they
actually took a little bit of a lag of
time to respond to the network when they
responded so we think that this is a
very powerful tool to select the cohort
that we have to move on into chemical
priors for example if I'm gonna do like
a clinical trial for igf-1 I'll probably
probably only recruit or expect only the
top four to respond to igf-1 compared to
to the whole population because it's so
a heterogeneous so we are trying to
understand why this happens at the
genetic level as well but nonetheless
these are mini brains or organoids in a
dish and actually point you to who is
gonna respond to a specific drug and who
are not responders so it might save lots
of money in future clinical trials so
I'll actually finish here so I have time
to discuss a little bit by thanking the
members of my lab I pointed to some of
them on specific projects here but also
for the families in subjects who are
always so very connected to my lab which
is something that I really appreciate
and I always helping in not only with
materials information but also giving
insights into the research I'm very
grateful to have these social network of
families integrated plugged in with my
lab so people appreciate that as well so
I mean this is these life that I have
all finish here I don't know if you want
to discuss some of the data or or have
any questions yeah yeah yeah certainly
like you mentioned that at the end like
there is that discrepancy in like not
everybody responds to the same thing but
they have similar phenotypes in terms of
neurons which are not responding very
well and all so do you think it is
genetic at the genetic level the
difference comes in i I think so we have
at least some indication that the genes
that are mutated in those patients that
are responders versus no responders
there is likely different and that may
affect the metabolic pathways that IGF
is using to increase
motivation or to increase in after
Genesis but the number in the number of
patients we have right now it's quite on
the lower side to make any conclusions
about that I mean one would have to do
that with a hundred patients or even
more to make sure that this is the
direct link the technology is so
expensive so it's so expensive to
reprogram cells on patients do all these
analysis that we cannot afford to do it
with large cohorts of patients I think
as we reduce our costs their patients we
can do more and more but right now this
is one of the limitations of the
technology and these IGF and all are
these like do they enter the brain and
how does it go like are you looking at
some of the molecules which will enter
the blood-brain barrier
yeah that that's a great question i jf
as we test it now it's a very it's a big
molecule and we have the full-length izf
one in a dish because we can just expose
them directly to neurons thinking
clinically one who have to infuse igf-1
and very few would actually get to the
brain so there are companies looking for
is more molecules or peptides that can
mimic what IGF is doing and penetrates
much better in the brain so there are
actually clinical trials going on both
with the full-length molecule as well as
with is more treat peptides that that
might work better so these are all in
clinical trials now and again going back
the IGF
like IGF might be involved in various
other things so metabolic disorders and
all those things have you looked at any
connection between these and the
metabolic disorders in seven cases we do
have a clear evidence that the
individual has a metabolic disorder as
well on top of autism and which makes
just that I chef my really work in those
cases work much better there are some
indications in the literature that some
of the patients that we think has autism
they do have a metabolic disorder and I
think those cases would be easier to
treat but to do that unfortunately you
need genome sequencing and this is
something that is not on the clinics yet
I mean doctors are not prescribing
routinely genome sequencing to all
autistic patients so I think in the
future this should be recommended right
now probably it's a cost issue not in
and also I mean knowledge not many
doctors are prescribing that but I I can
tell that in the near future we're gonna
learn more and more about the variants
the genetic variants that will help us
to personalize the treatment to a
specific individual and IEF might be one
of those treatments that will work
really well in some of those patients
with clear genetic metabolic disorders
so have you looked into any other other
than IGF like you talked about various
like the problems with in terms of
spines not having spines synapse
formation problems is there any
cytoskeletal related stuff in order in
there yeah yeah so both of the cause all
ever mean we can see that some of those
genes when mutated the involvement in
cytoskeleton organization in that may
explain why they do not make as many
synapses as we would expect but we have
been exploring other drugs as well so we
have several motivators of
neurotransmitters that can actually act
in directly into these networks in in in
correct and network to the control level
so these are
again drugs that can modulate specific
neurotransmitters that that we identify
as being low or high in the disease
state compared to controls another
possibility as I mentioned I mean since
the rats Ingram brains have these high
levels of il-6 one can use one can
neutralize il-6
in the brain and see if that helps so we
have those reagents now there is
actually one drug that has been using
for arthritis to inhibit
io6 and we gonna try to repurpose that
for for autism Rhett syndrome autism so
we have to do all the preclinical stages
before we move into the clinical phase
clinical trials but this is certainly
something that was unexpected to us I
mean we knew that in autism there is an
inflammatory component but we not and we
never thought that would be causal we
thought that this was a consequence of
the disease process but now I'm changing
my mind actually the data is showing us
that no it's actually causal so if you
block I or 6 or reduce il-6
you may ameliorate the condition okay I
think we are almost out of time I really
thank you for taking time to do this and
certainly it would benefit a lot of
viewers and I really appreciate your
time and good luck with your future work
and thanks again thank you thank you I
hope I convey a little bit of the
science that we do and who is clear and
if you know what I mean feel free to
contact me who if you guys have more
questions or be happy to answer them and
in congrats to you for putting this
together I feel that again we need more
more science speaking you know open
platforms like this one thanks again
thank you thank you bye